always wondered when you do the work
that you do you've always done it
quantitatively and you look for evidence
but is there at any point people say
what do you hope to discover how do you
react to that the thing that we're
interested in most is ourselves that's
what people want to talk about and think
about as ourselves and in this case what
we're trying to do is figure out how we
fit into the cosmos what is our place in
the universe I think that's what
intrigues people there are all kinds of
possibilities so perhaps we will
discover another intelligent
technological species out there and
statistically they're going to be older
than we are and the question of how you
become an old stable technological
civilization is a very interesting one
foreign